comment se forme le brouillard le
brouillard c'est un nuage accroché au
sol pour que ce nuage se forme il faut
que la température et l'humidité
favorise la condensation de l'air c'est
souvent le cas en automne au moment des
premiers froids la vapeur d'eau présente
dans l'air sous forme de gaz se condense
lorsque le thermomètre chute l'eau passe
de l'état gazeux à l'état liquide et se
présente désormais sous forme de micro
gouttelettes en suspension dans l'air
elle fournit alors une belle nappe de
brouillard qui en l'absence de vent pour
la disperser enveloppe le paysage ou le
cache complètement car les gouttelettes
d'eau diffuse la lumière dans tous les
sens et empêche d'y voir bien loin quand
on est dans le brouillard une dernière
précision pour vous éclairer
complètement sur cette question en
france c'est le mont aigoual dans les
cévennes qui détient est de loin le
record annuel de jours de brouillard
avec une moyenne de 241 jours par an